are you for open borders no are you for
the wall going up no I don't think it'll
make a big difference I think well the
overwhelming majority of people who are
undocumented and are here are
overstaying visas they're coming in from
other countries anyway so I think that
the best way we can cut down on
undocumented immigration would be to
work with the countries people are
coming from to reduce corruption and
improve the economies I think it'll be
cheaper and I think it'll be more
effective amazing and so there are a
caravan of illegal aliens coming out
between three to four thousand uh 400
000 I think stuff like that uh are you
happy when you turn on the TV and you
see these people coming I'm not for so I
mean I'm against crossing the border
over here we putting the wall up before
they get there so they can't cross we
could make it so that they're not even
trying to come over here if we actually
worked with the countries they're coming
from to improve the economy